does everybody know what like mapreduce
framework Tsar and has anyone used
Hadoop in their job or otherwise how
about disco any disco users in the crowd
all right so what I'm going to what I'm
going to talk about today is disco it's
a it's a started life as a MapReduce
framework but since disco 5 it's much
more so a little bit of history on that
produce google released its paper in
2004 I dupe appeared in 2006 couple
years after because Google did not
unleash their code on the world and
disco appeared I in 2008 nokia did disco
at their labs down in Silicon Valley and
they use it in production for a lot of
their a lot of their stuff but I've
never worked there but I know the guys
who wrote it spark is a kind of in the
same vein as all of these other projects
and the modern disco is more comparable
to spark than it is to Hadoop actually
so what is disco it's an open source
project obviously it's part of the num
focus family so you can install it with
anaconda um it's you know it's got a
distributed file system much like Hadoop
has HDFS disco has d DFS which is a and
I mean the spirit of disco is it's much
more lightweight sorry
it's much more lightweight and it's a
it's a lot doesn't have any XML
configuration files it's very easy to
install it's very easy to run you write
your MapReduce jobs in in Python
although it's a language agnostic
framework the back end is written in
Erlang so it's quite efficient and uses
the cores and it uses you know the
network very well and you know it's it's
a lot smaller framework when we were
evaluating I was working at an ad tech
company called chango when we decided to
start working with disco a few years
back and when we're evaluating whether
we were going to do Hadoop or disco
because we were a Python shop one guy
was kind of given the Hadoop and the
other guy was given the disk our
downloading stuff and installing it and
i think i had the Hadoop and I was you
know getting through my second config
file trying to get HDFS up and running
and the guy across the room was like
yeah I just finished my first job and
he's actually you know it's like install
go and it's really small and really
quite fast too that being said it does
scale up we've had a hundred-plus node
clusters on at chango we were putting 10
gigabytes or 10 gigabytes 10 terabytes a
day through it the new model is not
MapReduce anymore it's a pipelined data
flow and that's the main guts of my talk
is post MapReduce and it looks a lot
more like spark than it does I do ok so
it covered all that stuff who uses this
stuff chango as I said as a tech company
they're there on these ad exchanges that
you know process hundreds of thousands
of requests a second all those create
logs and they get processed with the
disco framework obviously nokia some
trading companies mozilla on my project
we're using it
at Mozilla as well I got none focus on
here because discos and unfocused
product as well it's in the family okay
so when I talk about post MapReduce what
am I talking about so that we've
generalized the execution into not just
map shuffle reduce its any arbitrary
number of stages so each stage has a
grouping and this is how data is
collected for the stage and a task which
is a user-defined function actually it's
more complicated like more sophisticated
than that but that's the essential the
essential idea behind it is to break it
in two stages there's a bunch of
different types of stages so that's
listed along the bottom here and I'll
quickly go over them because you know we
don't have a lot of time and then give a
couple of examples of what a pipeline in
disco looks like we'll look at some code
too ok so these are the way that the
different types of stages that you can
build for your pipelines so the first
one is called split and basically what
split does and say every input the boxes
here are like input files or blobs their
units of distribution in the distributed
file system the gray boxes are nodes so
split is usually the first stage in
anything it gets data out of a file into
into a process or a task group all says
take all data and put it on a one
process running on one node group label
is talking about the labels these are
partitions in the hadoop world or but in
disco would call them labels and a label
is can be output from any task so you
can split up data do group
group buys and so on so that gets all of
the data labeled and all of the data
with the same label will go to the same
task so that's group label there's only
two more there's group label node which
is like group label except for just one
node so it says after I've produced
labeled outputs group it all on that
node into one so here we've got label
you know data streaming out of a
previous stage into blue green and pink
you know label partitions and then
there's one process for each one of them
you might recognize this as kind of a
combined or a shuffle type of function
the last one is group node which says
take everything regardless of its label
and collapse it down this might be a
final you know process step to get all
of your data from your job so with these
building blocks we can then build
arbitrary pipelines if you're a
MapReduce you typically would change if
you know if you're in Hadoop you would
change ob's together to do something
similar to this a lot of overhead and
changing jobs together and so on as well
it's much easier to manage and replay if
you keep it all in one pipeline it's
much more efficient so the way that
we're going to talk about it we're going
to look at a fairly simple sequel like
statement and we'll see what it looks
like as a as a pipeline so down in the
bottom red there select X some where
we've got a group by we have an order by
so this would typically be two MapReduce
jobs because you select your key which
would be your group I would be X and Z
in your first stage and then your second
one your second key would be Z because
you're going to sort it at the end
so what we've done were just the boxes
here represent nodes the rectangular ish
shaped things are blobs or are labeled
data if it's black that means it's
unlabeled or just you know data on disk
somewhere once it's color-coded that
means it's been assigned to label all
that data is partitioned together so
what we first set up is a split and then
the output of our split is partitioned
data on each node then we do a group
node label to get all that data together
this would be like a combined so in this
in the split task we would be filtering
where greater than 25 and we would be
emitting it based on a group I of X and
Z okay in the second step so this would
be like a shuffle phase before a reduce
in the second fev you notice also we
have during a task execution pipeline
execution you can either sort or merge
your data and you get to specify it will
do it on the key right the key that you
specified so in our next box which would
be the same machines basically this we
only got two nodes in our cluster here
you would be running the group label
which would be a classic reduce and
you'd be summing up your why you'd also
do that in the combined in the previous
phase and then you start your new map
which is output into the second side
where the pink labels are and this is
where you're trying to do your order by
Zen which is your final group all into
the into the output so it looks a little
hairy but it's pretty similar to to
MapReduce except it's arbitrary
pipelines
what does this look like in code I've
not actually written the functions the
process functions that you see here I
and simplify it a little bit but this is
essentially what you're doing when
you're building these things again you
see there is like five you're doing a
select our process function which we
write would iterate over a file you know
filtering by X greater than 25 and
emitting out two labels up to our three
labels and the sisters and the final
step there is a pipeline where you group
them together and then you submit it for
execution ok so the talk is just a half
an hour and so I want to talk about the
other components of the disco ecosystem
as well I gave a talk on the last PI
data in Silicon Valley on hustle which
is built using on these pipelines and
it's a column oriented database built on
top of disco using lmd be as the as the
B+ tree so data is stored as a B+ tree
data infernos a stream processing and
job scheduling language for disco
MapReduce and we're working right now on
a blaze integration as well so that you
can drive the disco back in these
pipelines much like you saw Matthew just
gave a talk on blaze about it driving
spark you would drive it this very
similar way so we're working on an
integration there I'll give you a little
taste of what this kind of thing looks
like in hustle hustle has got a
dsl in Python for its relational query
language and this is kind of what it
looks like so you do it looks very
sequel like but this is in fact Python
and you can I mean it's really for large
large data sets its importance joins its
it has this funky little where clause
syntax that gives you kind of a higher
level this is similar to what you saw
with blaze or sequel alchemy where we're
overriding operators to provide a little
bit higher level functionality in the
dsl you can do aggregations you can do
group buys and joints so this query I've
kind of color-coded the the different
bits of it and represented down below
the disco pipeline that similar to what
we saw in the last example and which
part are corresponds to and this one's a
little bit more complicated than the
last pipeline we saw because it also has
a join the cool thing about these
pipelines is that they're dynamically
created so in hustle if I just do a
simple select you just have one stage
pipeline if i did a select with an
aggregation you get three stages to do
your group by and so on so with a join
so as soon as you hit return in you know
this on this query in your Python
interpreter it would build the pipeline
for you and submit the job the cool
thing about disco is that the latency
for running a job is near zero so hello
world in disco that like light something
up reads a few lines comes back is like
a second and a half on any arbitrary
size a cluster it's really unlike Hadoop
in that Hadoop the same hello world
takes
a couple minutes right so it's it turns
out that a disco is really good for this
type of application because of its low
latency also because all the data is
stored as B+ trees LM DB that's a
project worth checking out to it's a
very fast memory mapped B+ tree and you
know so these queries especially if
you've got it really leverages off the
where Clause because it's you know
you've got all your data in ranges and
the queries can be really fast we saw on
very big data sets this stuff is a lot
closer to performance in vertica than it
is to hive bike it's it's on the same
order of complexity as verdict of
queries so check that project out um so
yeah I just wanted if for for anybody
working in the Python world and using
Hadoop you kind of it yourself to check
out disco it's a mature product it's
well supported there's lots of companies
like Mozilla using it and it's got a
rich ecosystem for and quite a few
contributors especially people at nokia
chango and and mozilla those are the
main contributors right now to these
these projects
any questions like dogs it step senior
well typically you would get rid of this
microphone typically you would get um
you use the same language for one
particular job um there's a bunch of
workers so so the main interface is a
restful JSON kinda interfaces Bieber
line engine about workers are kidding
written in any language the default one
is Python but we have
coworker an o camel worker it's pretty
fast sexual again they ain't used to
analyze sinners yeah that's nice yeah
are you do it in order like a club but
it was a really good application for it
and I would say that's like ninety
percent of the disco job to written in
python and the questions